this question here as with many in
complex numbers and extension 2
as a whole looks a whole lot worse than
it actually
is so let's read it together try and
unpack what's going on and then bite it
into a few different size chunks that we
can tackle
together given that z equals and then
they give you this sort of
trigonometric mess which apparently is
going to be a complex number you can see
there's a real part here
and then this is going to be an
imaginary part show that
and then you get this identity over here
so
this is somewhat like a trigonometric
identity proof in fact we're going to
change this question so
basically that is essentially what it is
but you can see that they also are using
this kind of
new ish notation that we've sort of uh
introduced recently
which is to take the real component of a
complex number and just address
that part of it so we're going to have a
look at i'm going to say
this part here see if we can understand
what that is
and then take the real component and
hopefully fingers crossed
will arrive at this part over here on
the right hand side
so for starters i'm going to take the
complex number
that they handed to us z equals 2 times
cos theta plus i sine theta and then i'm
going to substitute it into this guy
over here and see what i come up with
that was messier than i intended all
right
so let's write this out 1 on
1 minus z i'm going to say if that is
what we
start with i'll just do a straight
substitution to begin with so
on the denominator here i'm going to get
1 minus 2 outside of cos
theta plus i sine theta and then
on the numerator i've still got one just
hanging out there
okay so what can we do with this thing
well when we do division with complex
numbers
as you've seen before the key piece that
we need to work with here is the
conjugate
right so the conjugate helps us to
realize the denominator and then we can
start to simplify
things out what's the conjugate of the
denominator well it's not immediately
obvious
in the form that it's written i need to
separate out the real part and the
imaginary part
and then i'll take the opposite sign of
the imaginary part so let's
do that you can see in the denominator
if i expand
i'm going to get 1 minus 2 cos
theta and then the next thing i would
write is minus
2 i sine theta and hopefully
it's now clear to us there's two
components here that sort of stand out
you've got the let's choose an
appropriate color
actually i'll do it this way you've got
this part over here which is the real
part and then you've got this part over
here
which is the imaginary part so i can
write this in a way that makes it even
more
crystal clear and i'll carry on the
colors that i had before
so i'm going to go 1 over and then here
comes the real part
1 minus 2 cos theta and then here comes
the
imaginary part and i'm going to write it
with that factor of i taken out the
front just to make it
super ultra clear so i'm going to have
minus i and then that leaves me with 2
sine theta in the brackets as it were
just adding those so that it's clear
that's the
imaginary component there all right so
now that i've written it in this form it
isn't
difficult to write the conjugate the
green part the real part stays the same
and the red part i take the opposite
side so i'm gonna be slightly lazy here
and take this guy
over here and duplicate it so you can
see i want plus
that instead of minus uh and i'll do it
down the bottom as well
and then i'm just gonna have this one
big fraction so i'm multiplying by the
same thing on the top and the bottom
which is why it doesn't end up changing
okay so what does this land me with well
on the numerator i just have
1 times my conjugate so i will just
write this conjugate
over here like so
i don't think i need it to be different
colors anymore now what do i get on the
denominator well the whole point of
using conjugates is that
this is going to be in the form a minus
b
times a plus b a minus b times a plus b
is my difference of squares
factorization so i can do a squared
minus b
squared what's a in this case i'll keep
my colors for this bottom part
so here comes a 1 minus 2 cos
theta that's squared and then what i'm
going to subtract
is b squared now be careful the b
squared
has an i in it so that's going to become
my negative there's going to be a double
negative there
and then i also have 2 sine theta
as part of b so they're also squared
that's all divided okay so
now i can do a little more simplifying
here but before i do that i just want to
highlight
whenever you're doing a trigonometric
identity it's always helpful or a proof
of any kind if you've got an equation
you want to prove
it's always helpful to keep one eye on
the thing that you're working on
and another eye like sort of keeping it
in your peripheral vision on
where you're trying to go your
destination right because that will
guide the simplifying that you do
sometimes the factorization or the
expansion you do it really is dependent
on where you are headed and what i want
to just point out it's not going to
change what we're doing right now but it
is kind of encouraging
that if you have a look at the numerator
up here this is where i'm headed right
i have a promising sign let's use the
right color over here so
this 1 minus 2 cos theta you can see
it's appeared over here and not just has
it appeared
but it is the real part of the numerator
which is of course
what we're going to be dealing with here
so i'll just highlight that that's
really good
it's kind of an indicator to me that i
don't really need to do all too much
more
on the numerator it's kind of ready to
go i just need to work with my
denominator
so what do i get out of this well my 1
minus 2
cos theta plus i 2
sine theta that's just going to hang out
there on the numerator
what do i get on the denominator well
okay why don't we
i've gone this far i'm going to keep the
colors so that i see where i'm
factorizing and expanding things from
so i'm going to do this this 1 minus 2
cos theta
all squared so i'm going to get 1.
minus 4 cos theta plus 4
cos squared theta so you can see that's
my a squared plus 2 a b plus b
squared so that parts there then when i
have a look at this section here i've
got minus
and then i've got an i squared so we
highlighted this double negative earlier
so this is going to become
plus plus and then what do i get out of
here this is going to be a 4 and this is
going to become sine
squared so 4 sine squared
theta now i can complete my fraction so
this is also looking
promising because if you have a look
over at the
thing we're trying to arrive at there's
a minus 4 cos theta there which matches
the minus 4 cos theta here
and by this point probably the wheels
are turning and you see the final step
of um
simplification that i need this guy here
i keep on using one that's too small
this guy here
you can factor out the four leaves you
with cos squared plus sine squared
but cos squared plus sine squared by
definition this is the pythagorean
identity
it equals 1. so therefore i can say
let's leave the numerator unchanged
duplicate that i'm going to get
i'll start with the colors now 1 minus 4
cos theta oh i will switch over to
orange for this part because
you can see i i got it from here this is
4 times cos squared
plus cos squared theta plus sine squared
theta so that just gives me
4. so i'm pretty much there aren't i i'm
on the home stretch
i'll just simplify that denominator so i
get the
denominator i'm supposed to get so here
comes the
the rest of the numerator which hasn't
changed for some time
divided by 5 minus 4
cos theta and because this is a prove
question and you you want to make sure
like you can't you don't get any marks
for
writing down the answer that was
provided to you i want to make the logic
as clear as possible so what i'm going
to do is
i can demonstrate that this one fraction
here this one big awful fraction
can be separated out into two separate
fractions here is the
real part over here on the left and then
here is the imaginary part over here
on the right and of course they share
the same denominator so this is 1
over 1 minus z so the real part of that
1 over 1 minus z is just going to be
this term here on the left which is
exactly
what i started with so i get to conclude
with as
required so don't be intimidated by how
much new notation there is and
and sort of how messy it looks if you
take it one step at a time and have a
look at say
okay here's a chunk that i can deal with
and i can substitute whatever
information is in the question
and then i can take other pieces and see
how that comes together
to give me the desired result you can
see that actually when you look at the
sum
total of the question and all the
working there we need to use what
knowledge
number one a complex conjugate in order
to realize the denominator
number two we had to do a bit of
algebraic
simplification factorizing and expansion
as well
and then number three also this simple
trig identity from
earlier in the course in trigonometry
after that it's just a matter of
notation